today we're going to talk about how to
get rid of low back pain
very fast now there are several causes
of low back pain but there are two main
causes that are the most common and then
i'll cover the things that are not as
common as well
and the first big cause of low back pain
is
excessive sitting
and you realize that the average person
in the u.s
sits
between
10 and 15 hours a day
that's incredible they're driving they
go to work they sit there or they're
working from home they're sitting
they're working on their computer and
then they go home and watch tv while
they're sitting and so sitting puts your
body into this flex state okay
now the thigh muscles which are the
quadriceps
um they're drawn upward in a flex state
and the quadriceps main function is a
flexor so it extends the lower leg and
the foot and it also helps flex the
femur upward the other flexor in the
lower back is the psoas and so the
quadricep and the psoas muscle if you're
sitting for a long period of time are
going to shorten
so as soon as you stand up they're going
to be tight and that's going to alter
the pelvis which is then going to cause
compensation to your lower back muscles
and put your lower back muscles in a
constant state of tightness or
contraction and so when you sit for a
long time you get shortened quadricep
muscles you get weak gluteus muscles
that's your butt muscle in fact your
butt actually reshapes becomes flatter
becomes flabby it becomes atrophied
because if our flexors are too tight and
we don't have strong extensors
which are the opposite muscles that
counter that which is the glutes
then your lower back has to take up the
slack that's really where a lot of low
back pain comes from so the best stretch
for this is the quadricep stretch and i
recommend doing the standing okay so
this is what i want you to do
now get a chair uh take one hand on the
chair
with the other hand on the on your ankle
and bring up your
foot into the back part so you're
stretching your thigh muscle let's start
with the right side
and when you do this you want to stand
erect and you want to bring your leg as
far back as you can it's going to be
tight and you're going to hold that
position for about 10 seconds okay and
then you're gonna do the opposite thigh
muscle and when you do this notice which
one is tight okay usually one will be
more asymmetrical or more tight than the
other and you want to do the stretch
about five different times with a count
of 10 and you're going to find at the
end of the stretch your lower back pain
is going to have a lot more space it's
going to counter all this tightness in
the lower back and so the low back
muscles be really nice and relaxed okay
so that's the main stretch that you want
to do now of course
if you have to sit for a long period of
time
you're gonna have to spend at least one
hour a day
getting outside walking
walking on different surfaces walking
outside with barefoot in your backyard
would be awesome because walking
barefoot stimulates the bottom of your
foot and it really supports the lower
back as compared to doing the opposite
where you're someone's wearing higher
heels or they're too elevated so the
closer your foot is to the ground the
more stable so the best counter to
sitting for a long period of time is
either
walking or doing a really good
stretching program versus an exercise
program you don't need to strengthen
muscles you need to stretch muscles and
make sure they're symmetrical the next
most common cause of low back pain is
low vitamin d okay so if you're not
taking vitamin d and you have low back
pain this might be the thing that's
going to just knock out your low back
pain really quick and i would recommend
about 30 000 international units of
vitamin d you're going to find that
probably within i don't know 30 minutes
to 60 minutes your back pain is going to
feel much better because a vitamin d
deficiency will cause low back pain
more than any other cause really the
next cause is
some type of asymmetrical muscle
and what i mean by that is that um
either the front part of your body
whether it's the lower legs
or the back legs are too tight
and so there's this asymmetrical thing
so when you walk you have this constant
wear and tear on the joints now this can
happen from i don't know playing golf
where you're doing this asymmetrical um
activity or even tennis where you're
right-handed that's going to throw off
the entire gate so for that you want to
check the flexibility of your joints so
you can try to touch your toes or go in
an extension mode and trying to find out
what motion you can't go into and then
you're just going to work on getting
things more symmetrical between flexion
extension
side to side lateral bending rotation
and even in your neck
if your mid-back
is tight or your hunchback or your neck
is tight
that can actually throw off your back as
well so you want to work on the entire
spine because it is connected now one
little point about this if you had an
old injury let's say to your ankle or
your foot
let's say you fractured your ankle like
i did
in college and it set up this pattern
where you're always limping a little bit
and you're compensating for the other
side
that can later in a life cause
your entire pelvis to be off and cause
low back pain so again these stretches
are very very important especially if
there's an old injury or a sprained
ankle okay if there's a disc problem
there's a really good technique to do on
the lower back and basically what you do
is you lay on your back and you want to
press on the front part of your abdomen
opposing the lower back so it would
basically be about three inches below
the belly button right in the center if
you press in there
and you're going to find a lot of tight
muscles and what you're doing is you're
relaxing the muscles that are opposing
the lower back
and
that many times will get rid of low back
pain so wherever you hurt in the back
press on the front hold that for a few
minutes and that'll knock out low back
pain
kidney stones can cause low back pain
i've done a lot of videos on this
there's a lot more information to be
learned about this but the main key
thing with kidney stones is drinking
enough fluids you need at least two and
a half liters of fluid a day and it's
very unlikely that you would develop a
stone if you did that and this is for
people that are prone to getting kidney
stones because kidney stones will cause
a lot of lower back pain but mainly it's
in the upper part of your lower back
if the prostate is enlarged
usually because the person is consuming
a lot of dairy
that can also refer pain to the lower
back so anyway if you have urination
problems at night suspect prostate
and just cut out dairy and see if that
doesn't help your lower back pain now i
recently did a video on the prostate you
should watch i will put that in the
description as well all right if there's
a uterus issue let's say you have a
fibroid or let's say you're going
through your menstrual cycle and there's
problems in the uterus that can refer
pain right to your lower back a good
remedy for that is calcium lactate if
you're menstruating but if you have a
fibroid there's a whole program on that
that i recommend and instead of getting
to the details in this video i'll just
put the video down below in the
description if you have pain in your
sacroiliac joints okay that's just this
to the left and right side of the lower
back
um suspect ovary um and usually sea kelp
is a good remedy to help counter
estrogen dominance to help some of these
cysts
disappear
and reduce the swelling in the ovary
and so your si joint pain or your low
back pain can go away pretty quick so
anyway i just wanted to create this
video on lower back pain to give you
some quick tips on what you can do and
if you have not seen my video on sciatic
pain
i put it up right here check that out